olá a todos sua alta aqui quem fala é o
dar que seja muito bem vindo é mais um
vídeo e os tragos de que fred desfaz
beers pizza a este é mais um jogo foi
uma m do fight night at freddy's eu
encontrei por aqui pra internet não é
investigar essas coisas ultimamente têm
sido muitos jogos foi uma do fight night
at freddy's eu ainda só tenho a
oportunidade de jogar
o fight 73 já elaine ainda não há
campanha série mas eu quero acabar de
ser em grande por isso está para vir uma
surpresa mas já depois disso o que eu
vou fazer com essa série tal mas vamos
lá então experimentar é que este fredes
fars pizza
pelo que ouvi de imagens o jogo está o
são porque o jogo não é dois de nós
vamos andar mesmo dentro da sala mas já
se mostra vamos lá então que começaram a
investigação
ok essa é aquela parte que eu falei
durante uma hora e não quer sair por
isso possa ocorrer só que estamos dentro
é da fox em pizzaria e faz um bom piloto
dentro do escritório principal onde
tenho as câmeras todas mas desta vez de
uma câmera na mão e nós vamos poder
andar livremente na pizaria pessoal isto
faz ser burro completa mann para foi
tranqüila eu apareço agora lá ok vou
começar já por isso concordou que
normalmente ainda parece que a ética né
acho que é isso aí tá aqui josé pinto
amarelo catar ela falar milan parece ok
taques é fred e o sequestro não poderia
faltar o século 10 da raposa já estar
por ali eu acho etapa fazer outra coisa
desumana rock eu ia tentar acender uma
luz mas tava mil
depois foi não gostou de perseguições
moda perseguições ou quem não está aqui
hoje a não ser a posição também estava
lá
ok pessoal está indo agora com isso já
viu sequela atrás de mim meu não vai
passar outra vez o toque entanto está
aqui ainda dela é essa vamos embora
antes que eu subi para trás né
esta é a sala de jantar e que a fruta de
ser o palco né
eu tinha um palco e os repentes e fred
acho que só viu
vocês vão se apoiar sobre meu bairro eu
não atuei curvado enrolado fosse o que
fosse que escuta que esconde que
discutir nas alas vassoura estar aqui
andam os dois se trata como eu não viu
não não passam por aí viu como é que é
possível esta exposição que meu
são papéis sampa seu país é mais votados
em forma de bola o que consegue fazer
isso assim tão perfeito ninguém viu
ninguém tá que o texto divulgado à
frente
halo já a cair ou subir ou cair regras
para a segurança
acho que é isso aí é 11 não corra dois e
ela de onde ela não sei o que isso é
3 não gritos 4 e não cair no chão o
outro foi assim não correta já que se
não ocorrer o sonhado meu calma lá
embora possa cada uma das carreiras
passaram a não confessar tudo isso não
ocorrer isso é muita pressão só então
pressionou dizendo lhe a volta fica
perto da tua mãe 6 num toque no freio e
não deixou e tudo
hoje o orgulho total 'meu filho da mãe é
sério tem regras mesmo que a porta e eu
fui até lá à frente para ver a porcaria
das regras e morrer como uma porca do
tietê é tipo não certos dons 8 livro vai
embora antes que fica escuro antes de
fora afinal assim for é
também que depois de a à h
vamos tentar outra vez porque eu quero
ver os quatro estudos deste mapa da ok à
frente acho que a 1 e não posso correr
neste ano o desempenho é isso aqui cetex
quarto é que um dos quartos mais caros
todas josé coelho calma calma calma em
uma transmissão e outras miné melhor de
todas as corridas brincou costa pela
transmil desta vez be rock seu barco não
está o fred não faz bem franco conseguiu
fugir à questão quem é o que menos tem
que rolar
as três são os deuses para este asw como
é que é possível twittar até ficar e é
isso não é só uma das máscaras e esta é
só é o palco nelson todos eo vídeo é
conhecido ele meu ok eu só não sei se
consigo achar essas portas e ao tentar
cortar em tudo e não lá só consigo o
cheiro mesmo na câmara e vamos avançar
então o pessoal chega lá embora vamos
ver o que é que esta noite no ic2 não a
um ou dois têm disse ao jornal a filha
daquela senhora zita criando gosto de
vender frascos de
doce de abóbora agora só resta saber com
detalhes de palhaço porque é sempre uma
campanha muito se falar em dolo por seu
filho também vamos dar a volta vamos dar
a volta
não vamos não taques a coelha amigo
deixando passar por favor
vocês não conseguem ver mas sempre tem
alguém em sã o pedro mim e eu em
colheres perante todos e parece uma
menina mas é fingir que eu não escutei
estoque e por falar em minas eu vou
entrar eu já entrei aqui dentro da alma
entrar nessa
todos me desculpe não vá canta os
laboratórios estão extremamente bem
feito
eu adorava ter um lavatório deste em
casa meus treinamentos depois de 800
fredes meus 3 a 0 eu vou praticar este o
meu eu vou parar só vou deixar uma
infinita inscrição baixem o jogo alguém
também vocês vão ver que é realmente
assustador
este foi um dos fãs mads mais estudos
que eu já joguei eu ainda cheguei 2 não
foi esse o caso
o trailer alan mas é isso pessoal quando
você pois fiquem bem até a próxima
o